foreign
let's go out to Memphis Tennessee right
down the road from me and talk to Lexi
what's up Lexi
hi Dr John what are you today I'm
partying what's up oh man I'm really
excited to talk to you I'm one of the
original 17 who's been listening since
I've
been yes way to go I'm so happy that you
are still with us I think we're down to
12. but I'm glad you're still here yeah
well I'm super excited to be here um I
have hopefully a a little bit chill
question for you today we this episode
desperately needs a chill question hey
can you uh make sure you talk directly
into your phone okay okay yeah can you
hear me now perfect yes okay so my
question today is how can I help support
my partner my husband who is struggling
with ADHD
and also get the support and help that I
need to
are you my wife
I thought you might say
no but she always threatens to call the
show and be like hey I love a guy who
has a marriage show but how do I get him
to take the trash out so
yeah I I thought you might say something
like that based on you know listening
for a while what is ADHD how does it
manifest in your house what are you what
are you tired of
um so my husband is awesome he's
creative and fun and a really good dad
um but he does
tend to be forgetful
um of things or they're easily
distracted or overwhelmed
um and I know you always say to lead
with us we have a 10 month old baby okay
and so some of the things in the past
that I've been able to catch
um I can't because I'm also managing a
baby
um and it's it's little things that add
up to big things you know like hey you
know we both work full-time outside of
the home and we've got a division of
these are the things he's in charge of
these are the things I'm in charge of
and some of them he does really great
but then the trash only gets to the curb
like once a month
um and that a little thing you know but
it does add up over time where I end up
feeling like I have to be
on like hey did this get done did this
get done to get this get done oh gosh
it's happening it's happening I can tell
you know you know what I'm about to say
right
um maybe you are becoming the mother of
two
right and I don't want that I
desperately don't want that but you are
you are yeah and so how do you know he
has ADHD
um so he was diagnosed as a kid and then
he had an evaluation as an adult where
he was diagnosed um I actually didn't
find out he had ADHD and so we had been
married for more than a year because he
forgot
no he didn't yeah he didn't no he didn't
listen if you Google ADHD my picture
comes up we don't forget we just think
that this time it will be it will be
different yeah and honestly it hasn't
been as much of an issue in the past as
it is now and he straight up said like
I'm struggling with it right now right
correct our life is more chaotic we have
a small baby yes we became homeowners
our house needs work like I understand
why it's it's flared up now but I don't
want to be a mom of two I want to be a
supportive partner but also
um doesn't become resentful okay
so you know this I'm just going to run
through this for the audience grown men
myself included with ADD ADHD act like
children a lot
um and the women in our lives become
they act like our moms
and then when people with ADHD feel
controlled they have one response and
that's explode they lash out or they run
away right like a child does right and
no Mom wants to sleep with her son and
vice versa so you get in this weird trap
of the only thing that helps ADHD is
connection and the only thing that
begins to slowly nobody wants to sleep
with a guy I don't know what time it is
or hey let's have sex at eight o'clock
tonight and it's 8 45 and he's just
getting into the chat like whatever
right you you know that whole Loop
um and what's what's my joke like I will
get in the shower at 7 58 and um
for an eight o'clock meeting that is 30
minutes away from my house and I'll get
out of the shower at 8 15 and be pissed
that I'm late like like it just happened
right
oh geez
um okay so a couple of
for for just the general audience poor
self-regulation
um extra sensitivity to environment to
um psychology to nutrition these kind of
things time my wife calls it my magic
time
mm-hmm
just magic time just like oh yeah I'll
get those uh the the trash and I'll get
in a second in a second is it's about a
30-day buffer uh the second right
it's between now and October it'll it'll
get done and here's the other thing
that's annoying it usually gets done
just not in the picture that the you you
guys you guys agreed on right
the uh the the handicapped parking spot
it's just a second I'll just pull right
in there just a second that the rules
apply to everybody except for me right
yeah sometimes okay exactly yeah they
applied it to everybody but me except
when they apply to me all right here's
the path forward and let me tell you
this the encouragement side is on the
other side of this
um I've made some extraordinary Headway
Headway no medication just I've made
some extraordinary Headway okay
are you ready for what I'm gonna say
I am you're not gonna like it I know the
first thing and most important thing is
your husband has to want to change
yeah
he has to want this to be different not
because you're nagging him
but he wants to have to he has to choose
a more peaceful life and for somebody
with an adult with ADHD especially a
successful adult with ADHD it feels like
you're giving up your superpower
it feels like if I'm not always a little
bit late a little bit by the seat of my
pants a little bit over prepared I don't
have that adrenaline push and it feels
like I'm not my best self and that's a
just it's a lie it's not true
but I have to feel like I'm letting I'm
setting the sword down a little bit and
that's scary
yeah and he's expressed Express that
like
frustrating to him there we go okay
that's it
he's looking for resources he told me he
was like I was listening to this book
about managing your ADHD as an adult and
the first thing they said was pay
attention and it made me want to throw
the book listen there's only one book to
read that's it one book and it's by
Gabor mate m-a-t-e in the book is called
scattered that's it
that's a book you'll need to read
together it's a very hard book to read
because he traces ADHD all the way back
to maternal stress
yeah and that honestly would make sense
here ADHD is a learned response a body's
response to chaos and yes there may be
some genetic components there may be
some X and y's and z but it is a body's
learned response to chaos the Gabor mate
does Dr mate does a great job he
expresses attention like a traffic cop
at an a busy intersection and the cars
are coming the cars are coming and in a
person with ADHD the cars are all
driving the same speed it's just that
the traffic cop is asleep on the grass
and you gotta get you gotta decide I'm
gonna wake this person up to the direct
traffic otherwise the traffic just gets
all the decisions got to be made
everything gets piled up and you throw a
10 month on top of that and then normal
marriage issues that come from having a
10 month old in the house and a new
house and a mortgage and all that
but that traffic cop is like dude I'm
taking four Xanax I'm out right you're
just gonna I'm gonna pass out on the
side of the road right so you got to get
that book
you can't be his mom you got to be his
wife
yeah and that means you all need to sit
down together and choose your battles
here's what I mean
sometimes the fact that the dishwasher
is is filled up
and it's not filled up like you would do
it those are two separate things
sometimes my wife and I pack different
suitcases when we travel because the way
I pack my suitcase makes my wife want to
set her hair on fire just to feel pain
just to feel something and she does it
in such an orderly fashion it's amazing
when she opens it up I've watched her do
it and I've tried to duplicate it and it
just I can't do it but
we both are going to get our bags packed
and we're both going to go to the same
vacation have a great time and she's
learned to open her hands on
this just the suitcase is going to look
differently and I've learned I've got to
have my bag packed the night before
because it makes my wife feel safe
yeah uh I think is part of the
conversation that we need to keep having
well it needs to be written down in a
very direct conversation because often
moms talk to their kids in very circular
manners and so I want the language for
you to be not things that annoy you this
is what makes me feel safe and this is
what makes me feel loved
when you are on time it makes me feel
like you see me and you love me
when you are late it makes me feel like
you are disrespecting me and you that
your time is more valuable than my time
that was the conversation that changed
my life
yeah that that sounds
like it would be really helpful and
we've started to have some of those
conversations but they can't be
conversations because ADHD people
experience emotions in a heightened
sense in the emotional regulation takes
over and it becomes the greatest
conversation we've ever had and the sex
afterwards is amazing and then I forgot
everything we talked about
all right
right
yeah you're like crap are you in my
house yes I am in your house so you
gotta write this down and you'll have to
have a needs and wants dinner time
make it a romantic date
and then he's gonna have to learn to
parent himself what do I mean by that
here's a couple of things that really
impact ADHD and adult people
chaos in the house lots of clutter lots
of stuff
my wife likes knickknacks and stuff like
that she has conceded and she has been
really gracious in getting rid of a lot
of that stuff and in some ways in some
parts of our house it's almost
minimalist other parts it's pretty
chaotic
um but in some parts
um it's very minimalist it's peaceful
and allows a over stimulated brain to
slow down a little bit okay also eating
right in exercise is huge for the adult
with ADHD
huge I cannot miss a day
period
in my whole team everybody in the team
knows now if they walk by my desk or
they come to ask me something I'm eating
a bag of gummy candy they all just know
oh well he's off the off the wagon
and there's a there's a ripple effect
and so here's the sentence you've
probably heard me say this on the show
before here's the sentence that my wife
gives me here's a sentence I give myself
don't forget to remember that's just the
gentle sentence she gives me
when I'm when I am coming away from a
pizza buffet and I'm on round three and
I've got them piled up really high she
will just gently put her skin on my skin
she'll touch her my her hand on my arm
and she'll say don't forget to remember
how you're gonna feel tomorrow morning
that's it she doesn't say oh my gosh
you're getting fatter Are you seriously
gonna eat all that she doesn't see any
of that because I'm overly sensitive I
feel it really heavy when she says that
she just simply puts her hand on my arm
and says don't forget how you're going
to feel tomorrow and I always go oh God
I'm gonna feel terrible and now I'm
gonna set this thing down see what I'm
saying
yeah for sure and I think we've in the
past we've been better without you know
having a new baby has definitely turned
King Paul I think one thing relative to
that that I've struggled with is it's
very All or Nothing
it's either I have to be up at 5am every
day to do my workout or I'm not going to
get up any days
yep yeah and as a partner for that it's
a little bit like okay what version of
You Are you this week
ah I think you are my wife I think you
are lucky
yes yes
and
um
I'll tell you another book that was
revolutionary for me and it is not a
mental health book and I told him I told
him to his face uh the book discipline
equals Freedom by Jocko willing
it's written in gigantic font
like a like a military Field Manual
you can read the whole book in an
afternoon
but it's very very clear and it was the
first book I ever read that basically
said you can live a life of misery and
Chaos forever
or you can begin to flatten out your
life a little bit and do the same things
over and over again regardless of how
you feel regardless of how tired you
think you are always discipline is the
path and discipline has such a bad
connotation right all it means is I
don't care how I feel I'm just going to
get up at the same time every day I
don't care quote-unquote how I feel I'm
going to do some sort of exercise
downstairs period there is not a
discussion about this
and again for me my wife has conceded on
half the garage as a gym
a big a big nice gym we spent a lot of
money on because if I had to get in the
car and drive I missed a lot
yeah we'll work we're working on getting
our home gym set up fantastic for that
yeah that's that's that is him learning
to parent himself and every parent has
to parent their kid differently because
every kid's different
the big thing is is you shifting from
over him to with him I'm with you on
this and if you're late and you get
fired I can't I'm not I'm not going to
tell you you got to be at work
I'm not gonna tell you that you know you
got to be at work you're an adult
and those are really really hard
and being honest with him enough to say
I get really scared when you're late
because I think you're gonna get fired
and then we're not gonna have a house
yeah I think that that all makes sense
and but it's so hard I know it's so hard
it's definitely one of those things
where we try really hard and I think
we've done
fairly well with this to to look at
things of like the two of us versus a
problem instead of US versus each other
and so I think reading these books
together and you know talking through
this is helpful because we had a
conversation the other day where I was
just like look
I am realizing that you view the entire
world differently than I do
um it's not a matter of you it's a
matter of experience okay
like it feels incredibly insulting to me
to be in a meeting like I feel it in my
body
when I'm in a meeting and I gotta go
because I got another meeting
I feel wrong it feels wrong to stand up
and be like hey I gotta go let's finish
this conversation later I feel terrible
like it I can't describe it other than
it hurts like it's just like gosh what a
jerk mm-hmm
so I stay 15 minutes later in the
meeting
and I want to make sure we have the
conversation I'm honoring you with your
time I'm listening I'm paying attention
and then we go to the next meeting I'm
15 minutes late and that person feels
completely like I've wasted their day
like right I've totally ignored them and
made them late see what I'm saying so I
it's not a matter of seeing the world
differently it's a matter of feeling the
world differently
okay and what I have to feel is when you
do this it hurts my wife
when you do this the kids feel like this
and I don't I don't want to hurt my wife
I don't hurt my kids
and more importantly now that I've had a
taste of what peace feels like I want
that
and I literally don't see the plastic
cups in my car my coffee mugs in my car
when I'm getting out I don't see them
I'm too busy thinking about something
else like a song I used to sing in front
of the mirror when I was in fourth grade
and oh yeah remember that girl and I
wonder what happened to that girl
because I thought I was gonna marry her
I think she married my friend you know
what my friend did one time he and I'm
off to the races and as I'm getting out
of my car I remember don't forget to
remember how good it feels to get into a
clean car
and I stop and then I look and I'm like
I need to get these 14 coffee mugs out
of here
and then I bring him up and my wife used
to be like are you kidding me you have
freaking coffee mug and now she goes
thank you for bringing these in
mm-hmm
and short shortcuts my shame spiral and
it short circuits the whole thing and it
just we can move on
and when I have seasons of bad ADHD when
I'm spinning I'm just turning my wheels
and I'm carrying a bag of donuts with me
everywhere I don't carry Donuts but I'm
over exaggerating but there's Seasons
when she knows
my wife graciously says not when are you
gonna get the trash out but that's not
how she approaches me she does approach
me with
hey some of the signs are pointing to
you're not doing okay
how can I love you better right now
and then I usually drop my shoulders and
say I'm really tired I'm really scared
I'm not gonna hit this book deadline or
whatever's coming up and I we have a
conversation that we can talk and that
usually resets me
does that make sense that makes sense it
does it definitely does
and I think to like
what I'm hearing and what I think is
important is the answer is not just
don't have needs and manage everything
the answer is continue to
engage in the relationship and say hey
these are
these are the ways that
you know this is impacting me and and
you're an adult and so
um you're gonna choose different things
or you're going to do what you do and
I'm here to support you in making good
choices for yourself and
um ADHD is a context not an excuse and
most of the time in my life ADHD choices
are not made in the moment they're made
30 minutes or an hour or two hours or
five hours before
okay my cell phone has to stay off and
in my bag
period otherwise I choose to pick it up
and then I choose to scroll forever and
then I'm choosing to be late and I
didn't choose to be late I just chose to
check my Instagram stuff real quick
so the choice to be on time is the
choice to keep my bag my phone in the
bag
yeah
see what I'm saying so it's it's just
learning a new context
um you said something I want to touch on
before right before we leave you said I
know it's not us
we're not fighting each other we're
fighting the problem
I want to change that language with ADHD
because he that is part of him
yeah and if you end up fighting we're
just fighting the ADHD
whether you say we're gonna be on the
same side of the table or not you're
both fighting him and he's going to
start he's going to go to war with
himself he's going to declare Civil War
on himself and and that's that's what
ADHD does and nobody wins
I want the whole conversation to change
to how do we have a peaceful home
and how do I best love you so that you
can best love me how do I help meet your
needs so that you are fully able to help
meet my needs and that means you're
gonna have to be really explicit about
what your needs are and you probably
have to spend some time with yourself
because right now it just feels like oh
if you just did diapers and just did
dinner and just did this then I would
have ah that would work for a little bit
and feel good for a little bit
but there's gonna be something different
I need you to plug in and be a part of
this family what are the things he needs
to do to be fully plugged in sometimes
that means leave the phone in the car
sometimes that means don't open your
laptop when we're talking sometimes that
means
um Saturday mornings are exclusive there
is nothing planned on Saturday mornings
because that's when we go on long walks
and we talk together
you gotta exercise and in fact I'm gonna
do morning time because you've got to
get in the gym and exercise because that
makes the whole day better whatever
those things look like we're gonna
create a life worth living together
we're gonna create amazing life
with the ADHD not in spite of it and
I'll say I think it's my superpower I
wouldn't trade it for the world I wish
I'd learned to manage it a lot better
earlier but I wouldn't trade it for
anything
thank you so much for the call Alexa
he's lucky to have you it's lucky to
have you have fun on the adventure call
me anytime